for this episode we received some crazy
challenges from you guys we'll be
building the world's tallest ping pong
table playing while cycling and more
let's get into it two rallies on the
same table yes let's go come on come on
come
on get out of the way come on this is
yours come
on yes two for
confusing come on come on let's go let's
go go come
on oh no how do I miss
[Music]
that that was
crazy you're tried to hit me take
that okay sneaky
tactic a red card for trying to kill my
teammate good try good try oh that looks
very satisfying so what are we going to
do now bicycle ping pong we're going to
put the table on here and we're going to
drive the moving table and see how it
goes yeah it's missing the pongfinity
net
I mean what would we do without our net
if you want one of these nets and you
want to support our Channel you know
where to get one we're going to start by
walking okay he's going quite fast
actually how are we going to keep up
with
that no
[Music]
wores
it feels very weird doing footwork and
not moving
anywhere this is so fun let's make it
harder and bring out the bikes always
remember safety
first
okay that's
it
yeah oh no coming coming
coming got it nice
rally okay let's try and serve our net I
think we may need to cheat a bit here
and at half the
table really
[Applause]
close
okay game to one point just one
point
was it in I'm sure should we rep play
the rally yeah yeah let's take okay okay
okay we'll be testing does this work
better for ping pong or binton it's not
going
to don't
say this is hopeless table tennis
doesn't work at all let's move to the
badminton
Hall let's try the shtle bow here sorry
go so hard let's switch to the badminton
[Music]
ret is it
faster yeah it's
faster successful or no I call this a
success let's build the world's tallest
table so where's the blueprint for this
table in my head okay okay he knows what
he's
[Music]
doing what is this weird
sound I'm just I'm just eating
muffins what's that
building yeah you want to build the
other side oh it looks like you know
what you're doing yes continue please
keep up the good works
sir that this wrong I tried to help but
then he said that's wrong 105 midle in
yeah got
it no midle midle what is middle midle
of the tree the big structure so we made
it this far thanks to me and EML nice
killing
[Music]
[Applause]
it look how excited m is like he never
does C whe he's flipping
excited
[Music]
guys there there he is it's standing
that looks ridiculous the world's
tallest table tennis table it's double
my height yeah it's two end yeah
remember to subscribe to see more
challenges like this that is a
[Music]
tower the world's tallest table let's
go so weird to play like this you really
can't
[Music]
smash
oh
[Music]
nice nice three challenges for the world
tallest table the first one is playing
on the
ladder nice
[Music]
sir
oh you can calm down now I'm pretty
relieved challenge two two balls at the
same
[Music]
time
very nice Challenge three
[Music]
[Applause]
roller oh three Vol and we have to get
it roll on the
[Music]
table leave your other challenge ideas
in the comments below because this one
was a great one nice challenge is
complete said as well
ni